there is one subject on everybody's lips
today and they want to know why the
police were called to your house in the
early hours of Friday morning Ian listen
I think what people have come here today
seductive interviewer there you there
you are I I think people have I don't
think they want to hear about that kind
of thing I think what they want to hear
and what they want to hear is what my
plans are for the country and for our
pubs which is a very simple question I
think any politician our last Jeremy
Hunt the same question as well does a
person's private life the great man when
he answers this question I will move on
it does does a person's private life
have any bearing on their ability to
discharge the office of Prime Minister
well III look I've tried to give them my
answer and pretty exhaustively I think
what people want to know is whether I
have the determination and the courage
to deliver on the commitments that I'm
making so just to be clear you're not
going to make any comment at all on what
happened lost I think that's pretty
that's pretty obvious from the foregoing
I okay but I I look like I you know I've
sat where you say I know would I
understand the responsibilities I
wouldn't the first five minutes on it
had you answered the first question I
did answer it anyway